dans la première saison vous découvrirez
Henri Désiré Landru souvent décrit comme
le premier tueur en série français
il est accusé d'avoir commis 11
assassinats dont 10 femmes entre 1915 et
en pleine Première Guerre mondiale ce
série à l'imposteur rencontrait des
femmes veuves ou esseulées par petites
annonces
il leur promettait mariage et sécurité
avant de les emmener dans sa maison de
campbais dont les voyait jamais revenir
[Musique]
des récits de témoins clés pour
révélations les plus tardives Lina vous
propose de revivre l'incroyable enquête
et le procès rocambolesque qui passionne
à la France il y a plus de 100 ans des
documents authentiques pour revivre ce
qui fut un véritable procès spectacle
avant l'heure et pour tenter de lever le
voile sur la personnalité énigmatique de
celui que l'on surnomma le barbe bleu de
Gambais